if we achieve our corporate Mission we
will be a multi-billion dollar entity
that is responsible for Less death and
destruction from wildfires and
hurricanes and floods tropical diseases
are actually quite related to climate
change
so I see carbon Lighthouse as very in
line with the change lives
part of the GSB mission of changed lives
change organizations and change the
world that is all exactly what we are
trying to do
our customers control one and a quarter
trillion dollars worth of commercial
real estate
bull they want to leave a world that's
habitable for their children and
grandchildren they're out to try and do
the right thing but they're also in a
bind which is they are legally beholden
to try and increase returns for
shareholders and what carbon Lighthouse
is able to do is both reduce emissions
but also show that this is not just
possible but profitable and that's new
that's not a paradigm that the
investment world is used to and so to
show that it's actually very profitable
to do something good for the environment
creates a paradigm shift
globally 40 or so of emissions are from
commercial and industrial buildings 70
of buildings are investor-owned
buildings so these are buildings that
have a landlord and they lease out space
to tenants so the low-hanging fruit is
typically your lighting retrofits so
this is you walk into a building you
look up you see if it's LED lighting if
it's not you replace it with LEDs
commercial office building that might
cost 300 000 bucks and save a hundred
thousand a year so 33 return you know
three four times better than the stock
market HVAC optimization is the art or
in our case automated science of
slightly turning fans up and down and
boilers up and down to reduce energy use
across the system as a whole so you
don't have to replace any major
equipment you don't need a crane you
don't need a permit you don't need
construction just sensors and controls
to make sure things are off when they
should be off and tune and optimize the
system as a whole our mission is to stop
climate change it is to drive massive
massive massive action across whole
portfolios of buildings all over the
world
GSB and actually Stanford is the broader
University as well we're hugely helpful
in this Pursuit for a lot of different
reasons Venture capitalists love
high-risk High reward opportunities
that's what they exist for mgsb
connected us to a ton of investors who
have supported the company my colleagues
and friends from GSB have given us
intros to customers so the whole
university and GSB machine really kicked
into gear to support the growth of the
company over the years
at the risk of being preachy I do have a
piece of guidance for current GS beers
which is make your life matter at the
point you have gotten into and are
attending GSB you are now one of the
most well-resourced people in the world
go out on a limb and do something that
is not the standard go save the world I
am very pleased with the path I have
chosen despite the fact that it has been
ridiculously hard but there's not a
night I go to sleep and I wonder if I'm
doing the right thing with my life my
name is Brendan milstein I am co-founder
and president of carbon lighthouse
foreign
[Music]